من محافظه البيت ينضم الى مراسل صباح
العربيه سلطان السلامي السلطاني يسعد
صباحك اهلا بك اتعرف اليوم معاك على
السيده الحمراء
[موسيقى]
المشاهدين صباح العربيه يتواجد الان في
اكبر واشهر مزارع البابايا هنا في محافظه
الليث هذه المحافظه المشهوره بالزراعه
السمكيه الكبيره تواجد داخل المزرعه يبلغ
حجمها يصل الى 150,000 متر وربنا تحدث على
اكثر من 2000 شجره من الم- من المبايض
بمختلف الانواع اليوم الاهالي تحديدا او
مزارعين لي يتنقلوا شجره البابايا من
المكسيك والهند وهي موطنها الاصلي الى
محافظه الليث وعليها اقبال كبير جدا نتحدث
على احجام واطنان كبيره يتم تصديرها محليا
وحتى خارجين الاردن واخذكم في جوله داخل
هذه المزرعه مزرعه البابايا نتحدث على
اكثر من 2000 الشجره هنا داخل هذه المزرعه
الواقعه في محافظه الليث الاساسيه من
محافظه الليث مشهوره بزراعه التمور
والورقيات والزراعه اللحام اللي اتنقلوا
ثقافه البابايا الى الى المحافظه
تصديرها في مختلف مناطق السعوديه وكذلك
حتى خارجيا احجام كبيره جدا نتحدث على
اكثر من 320 طن سنويا يتم تصديرها طبعا
نبته البابايا نتحدث النكلاء كل ثلاثه
شهور بعدين تم القطف يتم جمع الثمار مره
اخرى كل بعد ثلاثه شهور يعني وهذا يعني
يعتبر على طوال العام يتم تصدير وقطف ثمار
البابايا طبعا البابايا شبيهه طعمها
بالمانجا او الشمام ولها خيارات في
الاستخدام كثيره جدا ولها قبال كبيره يعني
يمكن طبخهها ويمكن كمان كذلك نعم عن انواع
المملكه تشتهر بالزراعه العديد من حجم
البابايا بينها في الليل تحديدا في محافظه
الليث او السيده الحمراء لماذا سميت هكذا
وبماذا تتميز هذا الصنف في الهجين
هي اسماء تعتمد على حسب البذور وحسب مصدر
البذور لكن بشكل عام انواع الشمام لا
تختلف كثيرا عن بعضها البعض يعني اريد ان
اوريكم بعض
الثمار الموجوده على سبيل المثال يعني
نشوف احدث ثمار هنا موجوده ونوريكم كيف
طريقه او شكلها من من الداخل طبعا لما
يكون لونها اخضر تستخدم في الادامات
والطبخ طبعا لما يكون لونها اصفر تكون
يعني مستويه ممكن يشوف واحده هنا طبعا
نخلي زميلنا هاشم المعبديه يعني يقطعنا
كده واحده ونشوف صورتها من الداخل
يعني لو تشوفون على الكاميرا الان هذا
شكلها من الداخل يعني
بشكل جميل ولطيف ورائعه ذكيه جدا يعني
فمتاز طعمه يستطيع سان شربها طبخها وضعها
في السلطات كذلك يتم الاستفاده من
الموبايل في في امور كثيره جدا يتحدث على
مستحضرات التجميل والمرطبات وغيرها من
المستخلصات يتم استخراجها من نبته او شجره
البابايا بشكل عام يعني هذه المزرعه اليوم
يعني بافضل انواع الموبايل يتم زرعها في
في السعوديه خصوصا اللي ليش ليش يتم زرعها
في الليل هي مناسبه جدا في في لانه البيئه
الزراعيه مناسبه والمياه العذبه ايضا
التحدث ان هيك عن قيمتها الغذائيه والصحيه
بشكل عام لتحدث انه ثمار البضائع فيها
فيتامين باء وفيتامين جي وحمض الفوليك
وفيتامين ايه وغيرها من العناصر الغذائيه
الصحيه المهمه لتصحيح يعني المعززه لصحه
القلب ومفيده للشعر والبشره والعظام
وغيرها الجسم ايضا
صحه القلب والعظام وحتى البشره وعمليه
الهضم هل بالفعل المملكه حققت اكتفاء
ذاتيا بزراعتها على الشريط الساحلي
بالفعل هنالك عدد من المزارع على على
الشريط الساحلي تحديدا في من غرب وجنوب
المملكه على شريط الساحل هنالك اكتفاء
ذاتي من زراعه البابايا لانه شجره
البابايا تثمر كل ثلاثه شهور فاليوم لم
يكون عندنا اربع خمس مزارع فقط في مثلا
على في محافظه على خط الساحل بامتداد مثلا
200 كيلو او 150 كيلو فتنتج اطنان كبيره
من البابايا اليوم من ذلك هي كل ثلاثه
شهور تثمر هذه الشجره وعشان كده احنا
دائما بنقول له طول الموسم البابايا ما
ينقطع في السوق واسعاره طبعا انت تروح حجم
الكيلو يتراوح من بين سبعه الى عشره ريال
نتحدث انه يتم تصديره باحجام كبيره على
سبيل المثال مثلا ممكن الكرتون الكبير
اللي فيه له تقريبا 25 كيلو بينباع تقريبا
بخمسه ريال او الى 70 ريال طبعا حسب حجم
همم
ولونها طبعا وفي ناس تفضل اللون طبعا
الاخضر وفي ناس تفضل اللون الاخضر يتكلم
عنه هذا اللون يتفضل
همم الجاليات الاسيويه تحديد اللي يفضلون
هذا جوني يطبخونه في كيدامات يعني مع
الطماطم والمرقه وغيرها الناس تفضل برضه
الاصفر كعصير وك- للسرطان وغيرها
السلطان السلامي مراسل صباح العربيه شكرا
جزيلا لك دائما على ههه شكرا سلطان